اعلن نادي النصر السعودي التعاقد رسميا
لمده موسمين مع نجم كره القدم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو رونالدو البالغ من
العمر 37 عاما والذي يعد الهداف التاريخي
لكره القدم ب 819 هدفا فسخها تعاقده
بالتراضي مع نادي مانشستر يونايتد
الانجليزيه قبيله كاس العالم في قطر وذلك
عقب التصريحات التي اطلقها في حق فريقه
السابق خلال مقابل
جائزه الكره الذهبيه خمس مرات ونتابع في
رصد هذا الخبر العاجل عن الاعلان من قبل
النصر السعودي على التعاقد رسميا مع
كريستيانو رونالدو لمده موسمه
وفي هذا صدى معنا عبر الهاتف من الرياض
للكابتن عبده عطيفه اللاعب الدولي السابق
اهلا بك معنا اييه كابتن عبده على شاشه
العربيه مره جديده اييه حصل ذلك فعلا بعد
الكثير من القيل والقال ومن المعلومات ااه
ماذا يعني ذلك حاليا بالنسبه الى النصر
بالنسبه الى السعوديه بالنسبه الى رونالدو
هذا خبر يعني مداوي جدا راح يعطي
تداعيات كثير على المستوى على مستوى حتى
القاره الاسيويه على مستوى البطوله
المحليه على مستوى همم تطور الكره
السعوديه ووصولها ان شاء الله الى مره ان
اعتقد هذه احدى الخطوات الكبرى انك تتعاقد
ملاعب بحجم وقيمه همم كريستيانو رونالدو
على مدار عقدين من الزمن كان ايقونه في
كره القدم ما احد اساطيرها همم متابعين من
سته القارات همم اليوم نفرح صراحه انك
سعوديين ورياضيين في خبر انه احد اللاعبين
هذول ينتمي الان الى الدوري السعودي وخاصه
مع نادي النصر فعلا هي صفقه انا اعتقد
انها لها بعد كثير على مستوى الفنيه ولا
المستوى التسويقي على المستوى ايضا جذب
همم المتابعين للكره السعوديه
ودعم الكره السعوديه بشكل اسرع يعني يمكن
في سنوات الاخيره وجدنا الكره السعوديه
بدات يعني يعني تتق بخطوات مميزه لكن هذه
الخطوه انا التقنيه ليست خطوه هذه الثقافه
جدا كبيره على الموس على جميع المستويات
همم يعني مستوى نادي النصر تحديدا انما
على المستوى همم الاجمل المحليا كبلت
كالسعوديه والاقليم
كعرب همم وايضا كاره على الصعيد الاسيوي
كما ذكرت حضرتك قبل قليل همم كيف ذللت
العقبات الاخيره وفقه تصورك ليس لدينا
الكثير من المعلومات وهي غير متوفره بعد
همم بانتظارها ربما ندخل في اطار التحليل
بناء على مكان متداول من معلومات من قبل
بخصوص هذا العقد ما العقبه الاكبر التي تم
تدليلها باعتقادك حتى تم التوقيع نهائيا
او
او او تقنع مجرد انك تقنع وتجدده يتفاوض
معك على العرض هذه خطوه جبار يعني خطوه
مميزه جدا لاعب مثل كريستيانو في في في
تاريخه وانجازاته تقنعه انه وتبدا تتفاوض
معه هذه اول خطوات النجاه اخوي طاهر لما
نرجع الكره السعوديه في الفتره الاخيره
اول لما نجيء التطور كبير على كل الاصل مو
بس كره القدم لكن ناخذ كره القدم
لما يجي الصخر
همم
المخططين لكره السعوديه كره القدم
السعوديه على رجل بخصوص القصص الكبير لما
عملوها مع انه كاسيل الان قصدي ده قاعدين
يعكسونا على المحل وبالتالي بجد كل
الابطال وال- همم كثير من الاعلام
والوجهات الرياضيه والقنوات والمتابعين
وحتى المشوطين الكره السعوديه وانا اعتقد
ان هذه هتكون اولى الخطوات الكبيره انا
اعتقد انه الخطوه الصعبه الاولى طاهر هي
كيف تقنع اللاعب مثل كريستيانو رونالدو
على الجلوس معك على طاوله المفاوضات
ايضا يعني اضافه الماليه للعقد مهما كانت
هذه النسبه او هذا المبلغ الذي يحضى به
انت تتحدث عن همم منظومه متكامله هنا ليست
فقط متعلقه
بلد الذي تتحدث اليه ده النادي الذي تتحدث
اليه همم هنا في هذه الحاله السعوديه همم
والنادي ايضا همم واسرار وانجازه مجرد
اسراره على اجتذاب اسماء مثل كريستيانو
رونالدو ما اثر ذلك باعتقادك على اللاعبين
المحليين هل تعتقد ان كله يجب ان يكون في
الاطار الايجابي او ربما يكون هناك جانب
سلبي يجب ان يعمل على همم يعني مقاربته
سؤال مره الممتاز كبيره جدا اولا لما نيجي
على
القفزات او المخططين او الاشتراكين كبيره
في الرياض السعوديه للمستقبل انك كيف تصل
تصبيح الكره السعوديه ورياضه السعوديه محل
اهتمام وجد منها استضافات البطولات الكبرى
طيب عشان انا استضيف بطولات كبرى وملفات
كبيره رياض لابد ان يكون ايضا لديه همم
حضور كبير على مستوى القيمه الفنيه لبعض
اللاعبين والرياضيين مهمين منهم كريستيانو
الاخبار المتقاعدين نشبعها
الان وهنشاهد يعني الباب يتكلم عن القيمه
الماليه الكبيره كريستيانو لكن الاسف
والعوائد اللي هتكون من هذه الصفقه اكثر
بكثير انا اعتقد من القيمه ال- ال-
الماليه لكريستيانو لكن خلينا نشيل الجانب
الفنيين نروح للجانب اللي حيضيفه كرستيانو
على مستوى
التعريف الكره السعوديه تعريف
مجتمع السعودي التعريف بالسياحه السعوديه
تعريب في الملك فاس الرياضيه السعوديه
اللي قاعد نسمع منها ايضا استضافه لكاس
العالم 2030 ولما تيجي بهذه الاسماء انت
قاعد تسهل لك العقابات وقعد تختصر مسافات
كبيره فبالتالي التداعيات والعوائد انا
اعتقد غير الماليه الماليه هتكون واضحه
بالنسبه للجميع لكن العوائد مباشره والغير
مباشره غير الماليه هتكون موجوده وبالشكل
واضح والاثارها قريب جدا اخوي صالح همم
تبقى معنا لو تكرمت استاذ سعود اليك بعد
التفكير بالخبر العاجل اذن
نعيد ونذكر بهذا الخبر العاجل حيث اكدت
مصادر العربيه ان النصر السعودي تعاقد مع
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو وذلك لمده
موسمين وبدات مسيره رونالدو في سبورتينغ
لشبونه لعب بعدها لانديه مانشستر يونايتد
وريال مدريد ويوفنتوس قبل ان يعود الى
مانشستر في ولايه ثانيه ومن ثم التوجه
للعاصمه السعوديه الرياض مع النصر السعودي
وحصد رونالدو مع البرتغال لقبي كاس اوروبا
2016 ودوري الامم الاوروبيه 2019 كما توج
بخمسه القاب لدوري ابطال اوروبا ويعد
الهداف التاريخي للبطوله
استاذ عاطفك كنت تتحدث قبل قليل عن بعض
مكان ااا يعني
النقص التي يمكن ان يغطيها
انضمام رونالدو الى النصر او الى بلدك
السعوديه بشكل عام على الصعيد الرياضي
نتحدث في نادي النصر فنيه همم اضافه الى
الكره السعوديه بالمجمل ما هي ابرز مكان
يعني
نقص بين قوسين اذا صح التعبير لانه دائما
هناك امور يجب ان يعمل على تحسينها اذا لم
تكن ناقصا على الاقل
انا اعتقد انه ال ال ال الجانب الهجومي
الشق الهجومي
اصبح يعاني النصر او حتى التغييرات
الكثيره في العنصر الاجنبي في هذا المركز
يعني احنا قلنا من الاثر ايضا الفني انه
انت غطيته اصلا عندك احد المشاكل الفنيه
اللي قاعد تعاني منها لما تكلمت انتم في
اطار التقرير يعني انت تكلمته عن ارقام
كثيره
ابطال اوروبا هداف تاريخي للمنتخبات هداف
كبير يعني فبالتالي انت مو بس انت ايضا
حليت مشاكل كبيره همم
في ناس او جوا يعني
يذهبون ويبحثون عن هذه اللي يغطون نقص
وايضا جانب التسويق الكبير وشاهدنا يعني
مثلا على سبيل مثال كره القدم في امريكا
همم
انها تعمل على هذا الشيء لان الكره
السعوديه
والمفكرين في استراتيجيه الرياضه
الفني انا دفعت النادي اللي راح له وعلى
الجانب التسويقي وعلى الجانب
يعني خلينا نقول الجلد اذا الكره السعوديه
عادي جدا فبالتالي هو حل شق الهجوم
المشكله سنوات
التالي اصبحت العوائد والفوائد في كل
اتجاه يعني قاعد تضرب انت كل اتجاه بحاله
ايجابيه بس هل تعتقد بانه يعني تم تدليل
كل العقبات التي يمكن ان تواجه وجود
رونالدو في النصر السعودي همم على كل
الصعده همم ربما التي
تميزه او تميز همم جنسيه او الغرب بشكل
عام بمنظومته القيميه الى ما هنالك هل
تعتقد انه في تعارض او انه كاي لاعب اجنبي
اخر لا لا اعتقد انه انا قلت لك اول شيء
اصلا انك تق ندوس على الطاوله هذا بحتى
تنجح
يعني انت قلت الوقت لكن الثقافه اختلاف ال
ال اشياء كثير لكن في سنوات الاخيره على
مستوى حرا
ك في بلدنا بفضل الله يعني الناس اللي
قائمين قاعده تساعد على دفع العجل بشكل
اسرع يعني فانا اعتقد انه العوائق هذه لا
اصبحت ما هي ما هي كبيره بالنسبه
اخرون باعتقادك باختصار الان
بالضبط بالضبط
الكرويه الفنيه واضافه فنيه في الكره
السعوديه بيحكم اول شيء الجانب الماني
وايضا الجانب الفني وايضا الجانب التسويق
لم يروح شو يعني لاو رونالدو الى الدوري
السعودي معناته انت خليت الان مجموعه من
اللاعبين الكبار في الكره الاوروبيه او
اللا
تينيه قرون بجديه
انه يحصل على فرصه للذهاب الى الكره
السعوديه
قد يكون تم التواصل معهم شكرا جزيلا لك
كابتن عبده طيف اللاعب الدولي سابق من
الرياض تحياتي اليك